very nice you then congratulations on
your success people love this show if I
understand we have something in common
is that right you and I we have the same
birthday with the same boy we even know
that because I'm kind of your stopper I
was into your high but we don't have to
talk about that no we do have to talk
about that more about how you love me
that's very nice so you you find out
what my so your birthday is mine is
April 18 April 18 I problems probably
watching one of your show in one of your
episodes and it was your birthday or
something I said Rick Moranis - oh
that's right let's forget about him he's
kind of muddy in the water needs to be
by celebrity birthday needs to be oh you
know April 18th like Rick Moranis and
then I found out it was you and so I
trade it oh that's nice tell Rick
Moranis he got the boot
that's very nice you and and well that's
very nice yeah well happy birthday when
it comes around I should celebrate
together we'll go out yeah call me you
clearly weren't thrilled about that
yeah now dude you must be having a lot
of the show is very funny do you enjoy
working on a comedy show yeah a lot of
fun I never really saw myself as you
know working in comedy and one of the
hardest things about it is when I'm
reading the script them and then it
calls for laughter like for you to laugh
your character it's really one of the
scariest things because I don't know how
to fake a laugh like it sounds like like
seriously and I practice and I practice
and it never gets better you're very
good on the show but this is like your
Achilles heel is to fake a laugh is
difficult I do not know how to fake I
can't do it but I imagine that like in
your position you've had to develop a
muscle for fake laughter senior you must
have to hear like a
yes I have no but you know cuz I'm a
host sometimes so he says something that
isn't like the most hilarious thing in
the world that I might
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the eerie part is I can snap my
finger and it just goes away I can't do
that so what I do is I got that's funny
see if I did that if if you know like
Brad Pitt came on the show and told like
a funny story and got to the end I was
like yeah and then the cat said I don't
think someone I went that is funny I was
looking right to Cameron he finished the
story and I went that is funny well
you'll get over that you don't need you
know you'll get around that the show is
really great though were you excited I
was it is do I get the story right that
Salma Hayek was the one who recommended
that you yeah she actually came to me
and she's like yeah I got this amazing
part I'm like oh my god some Hayek wants
me to do something and I was so excited
and I'm like and she was telling me all
about it's about this girl and and and
she works at a magazine and she's Swarna
she's wonderful and she's all these
things I'm like it sounds great and
she's like it's called Ugly Betty and I
was like oh so you thought of me
immediately like what you know but
you're you're very beautiful and on the
show they you know still they put
glasses they do a lot of stuff to you on
the show to to try and make you not look
as glamorous as the other people on the
program yeah how much time does it take
them to but well it only takes about
like an hour I mean it I wish it took
longer than that I'm really only an hour
away from ugly you probably are too
[Applause]
you're saying the truest things I've
ever heard an interview
our you're being very kind I have not an
hour away from us lately turn my time
aside okay probably an hour away for the
good I mean that's tonight that's that's
the thing it's true is that people so
much of TV is trying to fool people and
when I went on the air I decided take me
as I am and that didn't work so I had a
lot of work done are you getting used to
for example getting recognized I mean
because you've done some work before but
this show is really catching on with
people do you like that do you like when
people recognize you is it fun well
people don't I mean people don't always
recognize me they they kind of pinpoint
I mean they can't really pinpoint it
they're like oh do i I know you from
high school but then when they find out
it's me they're like you're not that
ugly or I will say things I mean they'll
really say you know it's true people I'm
always stunned and my wife is always
with me and we're always done because
people are trying to say something nice
but it's always they come up and they'll
say something people say like oh you're
much better-looking in person and I'm
always thinking am i or they're trying
to say something nice yeah exactly
now I understand that you had paparazzi
follow is that a fun experience well
that was kind of like I kind of took
pride in it for a second I'm like wow
I've arrived like a paparazzi is
following me what was they following you
in my head we were in an SUV and the
this paparazzi jumped on a moped and was
following us and and I was like what
this is kind of exciting and then it was
like for an hour and I'm like oh god I
please get the paparazzi off my back you
know right and we finally get out of the
car and the guys like I thought I was
following Salma Hayek he's like he's
like I've wasted two hours calmly
bursting my bubble I thought I was like
this big star with paparazzi following
me and yeah well you'll have that one
day and you won't like it and I'll have
it one day
and I love it Ugly Betty airs Thursdays
at 8:00 on ABC congratulations on the
Golden Globe you deserve it
come on back some time is really nice
talking to you yeah congratulations on
everything